[Musique]
il faut du temps de la patience et
beaucoup de volonté pour traverser de
l'ukraine en crimée
dans la file parfois des heures pour
franchir ce qui est devenu la nouvelle
frontière
à
la plupart de ces familles vont visiter
des proches le couloir de clôture qui
les mène à l'entrée de la péninsule
qu'il considère encore là leur part est
absurde mais c'est la nouvelle réalité
si l'ukraine contrôler les sorties
c'est aujourd'hui la russie qui décide
qui peut entre
devant nous la crimée sous la gouverne
du kremlin a changé en cinq ans pour le
mieux à première vue c'est une route
flambant neuf qui mène aujourd'hui à la
capitale simféropol
[Musique]
centre ville c'est la fête c'est ici
qu'il ya cinq ans des hommes armés ont
été envoyés par moscou pour récupérer la
bnf
[Musique]
c'est au corso fleuri serai
éternellement reconnaissante album qui
amène régulièrement ça fait à la statue
en bronze qui rend hommage à ces hommes
poli comme on les appelle ici voici moi
c'est poutine notre président du la
petite c'est grâce à luis ma fille et
russell est né en pleine crise peu plat
sans qu'il n'y ait de bain de sang à sa
mère qui se réjouit des nouvelle crèche
construite pour les enfants et dire
innovation en vie comme cette église qui
a été restauré gracieuseté de l'avenir
poutine dit la pancarte
nous avons beaucoup dépensé l'argent
pour le commun énormément ici énormément
c'est bon ça va mais il faut travailler
ici en commun aussi aller me tricot
machine qu un député russe de la douma
et un viticulteur il est venu en crimée
pour développer des vignes il ne peut
nier que l'économie stagne que la crimée
n'a jamais été aussi isolé
conséquence des sanctions
internationales qui sont plus sévères
ici que n'importe où en russie depuis
l'annexion les grandes banques
internationales sont partis il n'y a
presque plus de compagnies européennes
ou américaines
ça nous manque mais c'est un moindre mal
dit cette femme devant ce qui était
autrefois le mcdonald's
le restaurant a rouvert après l'annexion
sous la bannière de meyer burger blog la
paix une copie conforme
le serveur et le big mat et le mieux
connaître leur ordre
vladimir poutine gouverne la crimée
d'une main de fer
et c'est dur pour le moral du vlad 19
ans qui lui n'a jamais eu son mot à dire
sur l'avenir de s'acclimater débit
progresse il fait des études en
hôtellerie
car le tourisme russe est devenu le
principal moteur de l'économie grâce au
pont qui relie désormais la crimée à la
mère patrie contre ddt
cet isolement a même des conséquences
dans les classes de français quand 5
oksana ya elles sont presque verrez je
pense que c'est lié bien sûr aux
sanctions malheureusement on n'a pas la
possibilité de se déplacer en europe par
exemple il ya des difficultés pour
obtenir le visa
donc ça arrête les gens bien sûr des
mots croisés mais elle accepte sereine
les conséquences d'une réunification
avec la russie pour laquelle elle a voté
et ne regrette rien
à mon avis la crimée s'est toujours
senti comment une partie de la russie
à vrai dire et je sais bien sûr qu'il y
à des personnes peut-être qu'ils sont
opposés et qui ont une opinion tout à
fait différente mais je suis sûr que
c'est plutôt la minorité et de cette
minorité
c'est sans aucun doute les tatars de
crimée les musulmans qui paient le plus
cher
l'annexion par la russie l'avocat émile
courbit neuf documents depuis cinq ans
la persécution systématique et défend
les prisonniers politiques promeneurs
futur résumé extrême et plus de 40 de
ses clients tatar sont accusés de
terrorisme d'extrémisme et tentative
d'usurper le pouvoir
certains doutent ils ont même été
retrouvé battu m
il n'y a plus de justice en crimée dit
il c'est désolant vivre puisque ce
produit
cinq ans plus tard la communauté
internationale continue de condamner ce
qu'elle qualifie d' occupation illégale
du territoire par la russie malgré les
apparences et les airs de fête
la paix est fragile dans cette péninsule
disputer la menace d'une guerre n'est
jamais loin bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
craintes beaucoup de peur même si on
n'en parle pas beaucoup se rend compte
bien que la situation dans laquelle on
vit n'est pas du tout facile
vlad aussi y pense constamment ils se
donnent quelques années pour décider
s'il restera en crimée en attendant il
vit coincée dans une nouvelle guerre
froide dont il ne voit pas encore la fin